[Music]
hi I'm Tamara Krinsky for women of
Marvel and I am here with the legendary
singer songwriter and rock star Nancy
Wilson from hearts hey Nancy how's it
going really good I better know well
it's an honor to be here with you today
and we're gonna talk about first you
know so your song is in this film crazy
on you yeah and how did it feel when the
song became a part of the film it's an
honor to be in the film because the film
itself I thought was so aspirational for
women in particular you know it is
really amazing I think the way they use
music in this movie to help tell the
story and I mean it's got the first
female composer of a marble studio know
you know you certainly director of the
thing so it's just really great to see
teamwork like that and women sort of
being encouraged now more and allowed
more given the opportunities like that
so if you were gonna give a message to a
lot of the girls today about leadership
and what you need to do what would you
want to say to them I think it's
important to to lead with grace because
if you push people because you think you
can leave them or get them to do
something or make them do things it's
never effective but you have to be
strong gracefully
it's tough right people I would always
tell me like what how can you be out
front with you know wielding that great
big guitar on a big rocks big loud rock
stage and still maintain your femininity
and it's like well being myself and I
think that's actually a theme Captain
Marvel you know the things that you're
passionate about I mean you're so
passionate about guitar playing and
you've got a character like Carol
Danvers who's so passionate about it so
she was about flying with the guitar I
feel like a superhero who could fly or
yeah I really relate to the character
and movie alive well thank you so much
for talking with us
this has been a blast you can get Marvel
Studios Captain Marvel on digital
blu-ray or 4k Ultra HD
[Music]